en su postulación para ser presidente
saif al-islam gadafi se ve a sí mismo
siguiendo los pasos de su padre hijo del
ex dictador libio muamar gadafi es
probable que saif al-islam juegue con la
nostalgia de la era anterior a la
revolución durante el levantamiento de
2011 que barrió a gadafi del poder saif
al-islam defendió el régimen de su padre
miren cómo se ha movilizado el pueblo
libio hombres y mujeres han logrado
quebrar a los rebeldes
ahora vamos a trípoli y verán que la
situación está bajo control
en noviembre de 2011 días después de la
muerte de su padre gadafi fue capturado
por el grupo de milicias de zintan
cuatro años después fue juzgado en
ausencia y condenado a muerte por un
tribunal de trípoli por los delitos
cometidos durante la revuelta incluido
el asesinato de manifestantes pero en
2017 fue indultado por la administración
con sede en el este de libia también es
buscado por crímenes de guerra por la
corte penal internacional lo que podría
complicar sus ambiciones presidenciales
después de su liberación en paralelo
precisó de saif al-islam había estado
envuelto en misterio pero una entrevista
en octubre con el 'new york times'
preparó el escenario para su regreso
político si eres una figura prominente
algunos analistas dicen que puede que no
sea uno de los favoritos con la era de
gadafi y recordada por muchos libios
como una dura autocracia su candidatura
se produce en medio de un frágil proceso
de paz en libia en los últimos años el
país se ha dividido entre dos
administraciones rivales respaldadas por
fuerzas extranjeras pero un gobierno de
unidad que juró en marzo tiene la tarea
de llevar a la nación a las elecciones
respaldadas por la onu el 24 de
diciembre sin embargo hay dudas de que
la votación se llevará a cabo según lo
programado ya que diferentes facciones y
cuerpos políticos disputan las reglas
electorales que gobiernan quién puede
postularse